in the snow-capped mountains of the Moon
standing high above the Richlands of the
vale
stands the Eerie
a storied and impregnable Fortress said
to have been built by the legendary
Mountain kings in the age of Heroes
it is the stronghold of house Aaron
one of the oldest noble families in
Westeros
they're sigil
soaring Falcon over a crescent moon
their words
as high as honor
the errands are direct descendants of
andal Invaders who sailed across the
narrow sea and came ashore at the
fingers
according to Legend sir artists Aaron
known as the winged Knight
soared through the sky atop a giant
falcon
landing on the peak of the highest
mountain where he defeated the Griffin
King in battle you have to wait two
years until the next episode of House of
the Dragon so now is the perfect time
for you to listen to the audiobook on
which house of the Dragon is based and
you can listen to it now for free that's
right you can listen to Fire and Blood
audiobook for free it's a Targaryen
history book on which house of the
Dragon is based written by George R
Martin it goes from aegon's Conquest
until the end of the dance of the
Dragons which will also be the end of
House of the Dragon you can now listen
to it for free with horrible trial using
her link which you can find in the
description of this video all you have
to do is go to the description click the
link sign up for free audible trial and
choose Fire and Blood audiobook go and
listen to a long and Rich Targaryen
history including the current and future
events of House of the Dragon for free
it was the andel's first great victory
over the first men and so artists was
duly rewarded
he was declared King of the mountain and
the Veil
and the region was renamed
the veil of Aaron
thousands of years later aegon the
Conqueror arrived in Westeros
house Aaron bent the knee to aegon and
his dragons and were allowed to maintain
the control of the region as Lord's
Paramount of the veil and wardens of the
East
the veil of Aaron was the last of the
great kingdoms left old and proud house
Aaron did what they always did in times
of strife they shut the bloody gate
sealing off the Veil
then the queen region shower of house
Aaron retreated with her son the boy
King Ronald into the Eerie their
family's impregnable Fortress
from the top of their Mountain they
could look down on Westeros far below
its problems hidden beneath the clouds
but one day Queen Shara entered the
outer Courtyard to find her young son
sitting on the knee of the senior
Targaryen and ogling her Dragon Vega
beside her
just as he'd ask for another cake at
dinner little King Ronald asked his
mother if he could go flying on the nice
lady's dragon
passenger smiled at Shara
so Shara imagined did Vega
remembering her manners Chara asked if
she could have visenya brought some wine
or food she must be tired after such a
long flight but for senior demured bored
with his mother's pleasantries Ronald
demanded an answer poor boy
he didn't even understand the question
Sarah hesitated for a moment then asked
for zenya as a mother if it was safe for
the boy for senior shorter it was
what Joys did Shara have
Sun Circle the castle she collected his
little ringlet her own Region's Coronet
and the ancient Falcon crown of mountain
and Vale which the Aarons had worn for
thousands of years
Ronald had taken to the sky as a king
but he landed as a lordling perhaps he
considered his ancient writer fair trade
for a few minutes of flight as a little
boy would
more likely he didn't even notice the
three crowns at visenya's feet or
recognize the swords of his Garrison
beside them
over the centuries house Aaron remained
loyal to the Targaryen Dynasty until
Lord John Aaron joined with houses
Baratheon and Stark in Rebellion against
Mad King heiress
no Army in the Seven Kingdoms can match
the pride and chivalry of the Knights of
the Veil
they were the first true knights in
Westeros
the Knights of the vale were originally
the Knights of andalus an Eastern nation
whose people invaded Westeros thousands
of years ago
from the sea the veil seemed to the
Andals an ideal new home a wide fertile
Valley isolated from the rest of
Westeros and its kingdoms by a great
mountain range
the first man who held it moreover were
sparse and divided and waded into battle
with bronze axes and armor that couldn't
match andal horses and steel
but what the first man lacked in
Weaponry they made up for in ferocity
finally uniting behind King robar Royce
the first man smashed the Andals in
battle after battle reclaiming the veil
and pushing the Invaders Back to the Sea
from whence they'd come
learning from the first men the
remaining Andals United behind a leader
of their own not a king or a law
but a knight who'd been born in the veil
and knew it as well as the first men
so artists Aaron known as the Falcon
Knight
the armies of the first man and the
Andals met beneath the Giant's lands to
decide the fate of the veil so artists
had many more mounted Knights than the
first men who performed
with her foot but the first man had
seized the high ground digging trenches
in front of their ranks and lining them
at sharpened Stakes smeared with awful
and excrement
six times the andal knights charged and
six times the first men threw them back
but on the seventh a fearsome andal
Warrior broke through the ranks of the
first men and the Andals rushed through
the gap
King Robert had been wiser he would have
retreated and saved his army for another
day
then again if he if he buys it all he'd
never have risked his army of foot
soldiers against Mountain knights in the
first place when King robot saw the
Falcon Helm of Sir Artis across the
field he wagered that the Andals would
break if they lost their leader and rode
hard for the Falcon night the singers
paint a pretty picture of the battle
the king and flashing bronze armor the
knight in silvered Steel
but the jewel lasted no longer than the
verse of the songs for King Rober had
taken a Valerian sword of a dead and a
Lord and it sheared through sir Arthur's
Helm much like a bird's Wing through the
air
as the Falcon Knight tumbled to earth
king robot thought he'd won his
desperate gamble then he heard the
trumpets behind him when he turned he
saw 500 fresh and all nights pouring
down the Giant's Lance
and the man at its head was also the man
at robar's feet
so artists unique in that age or indeed
any age esteemed cunning even more than
Marshall's strength and had clad one of
his knights in his spare suit of armor
leaving him to die at roba's hand while
sir Artis took his best Horseman up a
goat track he knew from childhood
charge of the andal knights broke the
last great Army of the first men who
would never again threaten the new
Knights of the Veil
some of the defeated would even join
their ranks in the years to come but
many more fled to the mountains choosing
savagery over submission ever since the
Knights of the vale enjoyed an exclusive
position in Westeros
they could Sally forth from the veil at
will knowing that if battle went against
them they could Retreat through the
bloody gate where no Army could follow
until the dragons changed the game
when aegon the Conqueror landed in
Westeros the queen regent of the vale
shot the bloody gate against the
targaryens and masked the Knights of the
veil behind it to lock it but cassenia
simply flew her Dragon to a balcony of
the Eerie where the boy King was playing
and gave the boy a ride around the
castle
in return for his mother's submission
with the conquest no more could the
Knights of the vale hide behind their
mountains nor they soon discovered did
they need to
for thousands of years the other
kingdoms had Ward and treated to balance
each other's might whilst the veil kept
to itself
none realized what power the veil could
have until John Aaron defied the Iron
Throne refusing to surrender Ned Stark
and Robert Baratheon to the Mad King
the north the riverlands and the
stormlands couldn't have beaten the
other three kingdoms by themselves but
the Knights of the vale rode with them
after all the whale's isolation does
breed an abundance of honor and Pious
bleating which governs their decisions
instead of foresight like a blind man
who can only guess where his horse is
taking him
I doubt John Aaron had even prepared for
Civil War when he raised his banners
instead of handing over his young Wards
Ned Stark and Robert Baratheon to the
Mad King honor demanded and Lord Aaron
obeyed
he'd have done the same if the boys
hadn't been the Lords of two great
houses who could field Mighty armies of
Their Own
but perhaps I give him too little credit
after all if the war went against them
only Lord Aaron had a nice impregnable
Castle to retreat into and he was wise
enough to take poor Eliza Tully into his
bed to win the riverlands as allies
John Aaron won then John Aaron died
impregnable
that's how the veil sees itself shielded
from Westeros by its mountains
they call the engines to their land the
bloody gate because during the Age of
Heroes a dozen armies supposedly smashed
themselves against it except the veil
has been conquered those vaunted
mountains didn't stop the Andals who
came where the Eastern Sea the people of
the vale say that siren the andal
general flew on the back of a giant
Falcon and slew the Griffin King on top
of the tallest mountain
during aegon's Conquest one of his
sisters did the same flying her Dragon
over the bloody gate and up to the Eerie
the Aaron stronghold and the Aaron boy
King yielded the veil in return for a
ride on the Beast
here's until season 2 is a long period
but you can still stay in the house of
the Dragon World by listening to Fire
and Blood audiobook for free house of
the Dragon is based on Fire and Blood
book and covers the entire Targaryen
history starting from aegon the
Conqueror and his Conquest as well as
maker the cruel and other legendary
targaryens including the current and
future events of House of the Dragon go
and listen to it for free with horrible
trial using our Link in the description
foreign